corbin burns gets the ball
he has been impressive despite no wins
yet 20 strikeouts has not walked a
batter to this point
he's giving up all of one run in two
starts unfortunately zoen won because
the brewers have only scored one run in
his starts
brewers trying to make it two series
wins against chicago
to start the season and a swing and a
miss my goodness
change up i mean the superlatives you're
just running out of him with
how he's pitching this year you heard
tim dillard and
vinnie rotino talking about his
assortment of pitches rock that he can
go to
how about that changeup i mean down at
the knees outer half it's exactly where
you want to put it
arietta in two starts both of his starts
have come against the pirates
he's only given up three runs in 12
innings that's a 225 earned run average
i mentioned uh he's been good in
milwaukee four in one lifetime with a
276 era
gives travis shaw a shot here to knock
in a run with a fly ball better yet a
basement
travis waiting the pitch big swing
looping liner base hit to right travis
shaw stays hot
and the brewers lead one-nothing travis
shaw with
rbi number 11 on the year on a base hit
to right
he has been the best hitter the brewers
have had to start the year that one's
hit in the air deep left field
got plenty of carry peterson at the wall
makes the catch deep enough to score
shaw
and it's two-nothing milwaukee on the
narvaya's sacrifice fly
he just missed that good i think he
thought for a second that he got enough
of it of course every catcher wants to
be behind the plate for a pitcher like
corbin burns the way he is trending
shift is on for peterson the one two and
it's a strikeout gets away from narvaez
he can't find it and peterson
will reach first base no balls two
strikes account
see what he goes with here peterson at
first
and a fastball right there 98 miles an
hour
got a friendly call and an about face
for javier baez
burns could use a strikeout right here
2-2 on the way
and he got him slider that time
well yes for a strikeout you get it
pretty good chance that burns is going
to be able to come through
maria's hitting just 133 for the year
fastball strike three called ariata
strikes out urease
and that's going to be the second out in
the inning brewers leading two nothing
from american family field
and that is called strike three and
arietta gets them one
two three including a couple of
punch-outs we're headed to the third
two on arietta here comes burns and he
struck him out looking cutter on the
outside corner that
outside edge is open
full count with one away
and he got him right on the edge again
half
taking a second look at the home plate
umpire that had plenty of plate
backwards k strikeout number six
cubs with a couple of hits brewers with
three hits in the first four batters
haven't got that one on the barrel deep
left center field got some carry
and this one's gonna fly travis shaw
just leans down and serves one out
the bat is back
sending bernie down the slide travis
shaw
two rbis today he pops his third homer
and the brewers lead at three nothing
boy what an acquisition for david
stearns huh the way this guy has been
swinging a bat to get started
wow hitting the ball where it's pissed
the average is up he's driving in runs
cutter from arietta goes down and gets
it
and the pitch it is in there strike
three
looking and roll mine is gone strikeout
number eight
for pitchers to have the same release
point on every one of their pitches
some comparisons to arietta for corbin
burns when he was going through his
struggles
in 2019
got him strikeout to end it burns has
nine
k's first two trips through the batting
order
and he's put up zeroes through five only
giving up two hits
he's got five ten strikeout games
in his career his best strikeout game is
12.
and did he go he did las diaz is asking
for help
yeah he called him out rizzo's not gonna
run so narvaez
puts the tag on him to secure it he
never really
kind of pointed at him but never really
wrung him up
but it is a strikeout and it's number 10
for corbin burns got him on a spinner
good block by narvaez
[Music]
dress him up a little bit garcia in the
right center field that's going to get
down
base head for avi garcia
well he keeps it going two hits today
garcia with a leadoff single here in the
sixth
had a double to right center in the
first inning he's good
marbae is a little flared that is gonna
fall for a base hit
and john peterson fires to second close
play there
pretty good idea by peterson
yeah garcia taking a wide turn around
second base and able to get back
big spot right here brewers lead three
nothing
looking for more mckinney takes ball
four
confidently takes ball four at that rbi
the easy way
brewers now four nothing up in front
everybody moves up a base they're still
loaded with nobody out
[Applause]
oh miss bob it's another walk
and another run in five to nothing
brewers
this will be his first ever plate
appearance with the bases loaded in the
big league
burns rock has never posted an rbi in
the majors
he's found the barrel already today 3-2
burns
and that's going gonna fall for a base
hit
one one is in hira throw to the plate
the tag nut in time
mckenny scores and corbin burns
his first rbis as a big league hitter
seven to nothing brewers and yes he was
due wasn't he
up a seven pitch at bat ends up with a
base by a bit with a base hit by corbin
it dumps one into center field seven to
nothing brewers
a fourth spot a crooked number for the
brewers in the sixth
people's grills other people's boats
other people's tools
works well on the ground
shaw gobbles it up and it's a shutout
glenn bloom finishes it off seven to
nothing the brewers win today
and they win a series against the cubs
second
series they've beaten the cubs